the Joe Rogan experience I think we're
coming to a point in our history where a
lot of these people are dead
a lot of these people are in jail a lot
of these people got book deals and
people are talking and you're mean it's
interesting seeing some of the stuff
that it's coming out now that in my time
when I was active would have gotten you
in a hole probably somewhere if you
talked about it so there's definitely I
mean I my mind was blown when I was
seeing old chapel and that clicks
because a lot of stuff that was going on
in that Joe is fictionalized stuff that
I went through myself so I was like this
is on Netflix now how accurate was some
pretty good accurate parts so there's a
there's a character in that show called
we're talking about narcos and we're
talking about the Mexican version of
narcos right because we're there zombie
in first yeah there there's a narcos
pretty good there's a there's a chapel
series on Netflix as well oh there is
yeah it's in Spanish it's very popular
but it's pretty accurate
there's a guy in that in the subtitles
it does there's a guy in the show
Conrado
solo is his name which would nobody
would people were trying to figure out
who that was it's basically a government
guy that had a deal with a chapel and
they both kind of escalated in power it
turns out it was Luna alright so this
show was showing him the character El
Sol which depicts Luna as a corrupt
politician that was working security was
working both sides and all of a sudden
you know recently a few months a few
weeks back they arrested the guy the
show was kind of predicted yeah do you
think that the show had anything to do
with him being arrested I mean it
probably put I put the idea in the
zeitgeist of people to ask questions you
know yeah that's weird that shows
actually do do that like saving
surviving r.kelly that's what got him
arrested I mean everybody knew he not
people I'm like [ __ ] 20 years ago
he's peeing on little kids yeah now it
gives people like a good
it's interesting you see a fictionalized
forms up stuff that happened down there
the narcos show as well is another thing
you know see fictionalized things how
some of these powerful
cartel groups kind of originated
themselves in fiction and now that is in
the public kind of domain as far as
collective knowledge so people start
asking questions and some of these
things parently people in power also ask
questions as well Jesus it's just it's
so strange how popular it's become you
know and it's such a popular focal point
of fiction as well and in fashion you
know Chapel picture with uh Sean Penn
yeah
the shirt was fire everybody wanted that
shirt you know that Conor McGregor like
wore something to mimic it when on
purpose with a pro in the press
conference for Rafael dos Anjos did you
know that yeah you were stood he stood
in the same stance like look at him look
at him
I mean he's doing it on purpose yeah
it's like a subtle nod to El Chapo yeah
I mean he's a topless achieved legendary
status now we're sure now his kid that
was freed by the the the cartel down
there he was wearing a scalpel REO which
is like you could I don't know if you
can see it in there it's an interesting
just big piece of a cultural thing from
Mexico what is going on in this video
that was just handed the gun over hit
what his personal gun over to one of his
bodyguard said was not even these guys
don't even care about him this a head
head head camera thing and they're
putting everybody out there and
personally I would put everybody in zip
ties and on the ground personally so
these guys all have guns drawn and
there's people inside with guns drawn at
them and they realize they realize who
they have now so they're like should we
forcefully put him in cuffs are we not
so how do you know that they're
realizing this right is because of the
language they're saying I've went
through a lot of the same training that
they went through and I did a lot of
this type of stuff and all of them would
have been in zip ties on the ground
this girl went reached out and grabbed
their guns and put their guns down
compose there's there's fear in these
people they realize that they messed up
oh Jesus right so that's what you know
people question and there are these
streaming this video live that they they
have their head cams
headcam and they're streaming it not
well it's not you know that they have
corny recording it and it gets sent back
to the command post so when he was
moving around he had one of these on
this is a capillary oh it's called it's
like a religious catholic iconography
thing
what is yours what is it this is a santa
marta one right it's like a holy death
effigy so he had that on he had his was
a Santoni La Toja which is like a
Catholic this yeah Christ
baby st. they have as soon as that
picture of him went on online they were
sold out all throughout Sinaloa
everybody was wearing that they have to
work you know they work always work
because I'm free
god I'm Freya's areas that's a that's a
scapular do something you handsome guy
yeah that's an also an interesting
cultural thing the occult part of it
were that that's Anthony Itachi shrine
is right now it's probably most popular
shrines in Mexico or that one because
they work and then you go to the holy
death shrines down there as well and you
see how how both sides both Mexican
government forces and the cartel they
they both been re kind of the same
Saints so with that again that's a weird
kind of a thing they share that faith
what does that picture of his truck down
there Jamie you have some wacky truck no
just a regular truck that's his yeah
that's one of those little bullets he
gave out cars on Christmas as a like he
did this party to any like townspeople
or how many cars do you give out I have
no idea like a lot of them there's
pictures of the El Chapo son gives out
cars on Christmas and there's a bunch of
cars there you know again who who are
you
like who who are you gonna go towards
him of course government are you don't
give me anything yeah they like you said
hearts and minds they're really yeah
Hines and then and you know they they
they pay for a college education so
there's a whole generation of lawyers a
whole generation of doctors they pay for
immigration procedures
so hey you want to you know yeah I'll
pay for your immigration but you know
I'm gonna call in some favors later on
okay Wow
so that's you know that's that's how
that's how you grow it's full-on mafia
[ __ ] yeah I mean they learn that one day
I'll come to you
Al Capone Al Capone you know Scarface
all these things are kind of venerated
by them that's kind of their cultural
backing off cultural backing they kind
of look to the mob era guys as influence
or as inspiration you see you know
insane paintings of the Godfather or
Scarface in some of these safe houses
what these people are right and you're
like okay or you see cartel influenced
series for Netflix like there's one
called la reina del sewer which is about
a female cartel head and the lady that
stars in that show was the one that took
Sean Penn down there the meal Chapel
because I know Chapel was a fan of that
show really that's how it got going when
they finally caught up to him he had the
whole series on DVDs that is pretty
humanized and oh my god that that whole
scene with Sean Penn going down there
and writing a story for Rolling Stone
was uber bizarre yeah well if they get
the the terrorist designation he
basically went down there to meet with a
terrorist what happens to him then is it
all retroactive I don't know I don't
know but they he helped get him arrested
in a sense right he basically that whole
commotion put eyes on on the movements
of El Chapo by the Mexican government
why would he'll chapo agree to do
something like that he was a fan of the
show that seems so crazy though doesn't
it seem crazy that he was willing to
take that kind of a risk and take a
photo with Sean Penn and that that
actress well I was what's her name again
okay got it got the cop that cuts to you
yeah right there he's chapo is probably
banging that right if I yes
there's rumors there's rumors of a
meeting that's about it
no anything else yeah I have yes I don't
say yes that's just the whole thing with
Sean Penn smiling hey here's my friend
the murderer I mean
[Applause]